time for this week's pet project lori
herron joins us from the nspca she
brought along someone who needs a safe
and good home
how you doing lori hi kendall and this
lovable orange tabby guy here has a
creative name he is a roman general
named julius ceasfer
so i guess i should be saying friends
las vegas and countrymen
lend me your ear while i tell you about
julius caesar
here julius's story was found that he
was found wandering on the streets and
he's such a
lovable guy that we took him in he's 11
years old
he has an fib cat so we recommend that
he's either with other fib cats which is
a felon infection that's transmissible
or by himself
he'd be a really great companion for
somebody that's looking
um for a lap cat somebody to cuddle with
because he is occurring as we speak
he's one of the most lovable guys that
we've had at this altar
oh and i think his name is perfect
i thought i'd throw my own dad joke in
there yeah he's purring right now he's
really a lover
he has some allergies so we do recommend
a special diet for him
but he would be a perfect perfect
companion for somebody that's watching
today that
needs some love in their house because
julius caesar has
lots of love love it all right lori
thanks so much
if you're interested in adopting a pet
you can go to nevadaspca.org or call
them
at 702-873-7722